this is a production of Cornell
University
it is a pleasure to share with you for
the first time part of my research work
the title of my talk is RJ identifying
potential at a little group in Nigeria
cassava using using data from IT a
breeding program cassava my milk my
favorite crop belongs to a family of
four the osseous that is flowering
plants it is predominant predominantly
classified as at cost at crossing
species despite having both male and
female reproductive organ it is Llanelli
propagated crop cassava is extremely
heterogeneous because of this
heterogeneity nature of this crop to
improve the performances of publishin
cross is always a big challenge in
identifying the optimum parental
combinations it one possible way to
address this obstacle is to use
reciprocal recurrent selection to wish
you catified to through to Authority
group to optimize the performances of
the cross so the there are two main
objective of this study to estimate
additive unknown additive genetic
variance and assess the relative ability
in genomic medicine so the result from
this objective will be used to simulate
progeny from parent upon Benicia know
very well that to evaluate thousands of
progeny from a pair of cross is always
impractical in the field evaluation so
there is need for us to do two
simulation so based on this simulation
we are going to use USO to predict
genetic merit
of parents taught identifying authority
group so this is the general concept of
the host story
so we tend to have two population the
training population so this will consist
historical data from next gen project in
ITA breeding programs so we are going to
use those historical data to predict
performances of the progeny simulator
from the candidate population for the
candidate population we have to start by
identifying existing germ plasm in the
breeding program from there we are going
to simulate F dial L among the clones so
we are going to simulate one their
progeny per family and we are going to
predict their performances by using the
historical data from the training
populations so based on the me
performances of those progeny and
genetic similarity we are going to
classify them into two Authority group
so what is name so
have started to pull a number of trans
together so we have a total number of 30
trials across different evolution stages
brony evaluation phenology TRAI advanced
atreya a uniform you try across two
location Ibarra Andy Keenan so we have a
total number of seven thousand three on
there are 42 data points so we see half
snip data's so there's need for that in
order to capture the segregation among
individuals within the same family so
after doing all the quality checks so we
end up having training publishing size
of 684 samples by Jeff thousand three
hundred and seventeen stigmata so we do
all sort of analysis using different
kind of applications so one of them is
similarly in our so to start with the
traditional practice for it analyzed
data is to do some exploratory analysis
to have idea of what your data looks
like so this is the boss plot and
Instagram showing the distribution of
fresh fruit as you can see the data
seemed to approximate normal
distributions and set that of Crennel
evaluation which is a little bit skewed
to the right as you can see the point
which is the mean is a little bit higher
than the median so for this new beta you
know is always characterized which arrow
knows value to out that it is sequence
so this is the pipeline we follow to get
rid of ireneaus values so me theta based
on site business Manali frequency feet
are no dead samples
main web sites and the treshold I use is
the one in parentheses so after
filtering the data so we have to impose
this claim data using bigger so I also
you
plink to convert you to dosage form us
and the still have upper formats so that
we can use that to get a genetic
distance so this is the detail of how we
went about clinical data
Kesava be a diploid organism this data
is by allelic so this is the frequency
of the first allele frequency of the
second allele so we use just a manner we
fit a formal allele frequency using one
percent for deciding on signals we use
stress hood of twenty cents so that
those sites that of 10 and above across
the sample should be removed
likewise we did the same thing for the
sample so we use HS order of 10 percent
so that those samples that of tempie set
and are both missing data across the
size should be removed to be excluded
for this site depth the DJ Pia is the
number of sequence rate besides so we we
history a sort of ten a hundred soon as
those samples between ten are on
disability so those below ten rows are
the sites with low sequence error so
there are some sites that of high depth
due to probably repeat region so those
ones are also admitted so we are
interested in this region here so after
all these filtering criteria so we hand
up having na nan dasi 262 samples by
twelve thousand three hundred seventy
Marquez
so I think gaudí cleans the beta's so I
use some alhabi in our because it has a
kernel to stress the
relationship masteries so using the
formula adapted from an Delma 2011 on
fire and a 2008 so is the relationship
matrix as you can see here the so the
question is from these three component
of epistasis
which ones will I use in my models so I
try to come up with this correlation
matrices by a stretching or diagonal
element as you can see a DT by additive
is less as the list prevalence with
additive and dominance so I try to use
this as some may hug you why do you have
to use additive by additive knowing that
cassava is an artisan species so unlike
cellphone a drop like wheat where Aditi
by Heidi chief is well pronounced our
talk more on that later
so to start with the analysis of the
data
I used two stage approach so the first
approach is to analyze the phenotypic
data so frantic luna evolution trial is
the model I used so prune evolution try
is early stage of breeding program where
we have so many lines to evaluates it
because of insufficient planting
materials so we have to use checks just
also be replicated in a few blocks and
for the other evaluation stages we have
enough planting material so you normally
use randomized design this is the border
fitted so where the JUnit herbs are
taken to be random to admit the did not
appearance and this is the prop model
fitted so you can see this is the fresh
seed is the intercept part of the Monday
and this is additive effect so the same
thing for the so we use this as a
baseline model so the order multiple
kernel models the in addition to
additive effect we have dominance here
we have epistatic effect and luminous
and epistatic effect here so
so this is student eyes receiver from
the phenotypic data which is a very good
statistics to detect an outlier and this
is the the variance component estimated
from those different evolution stages as
you considered the receipt of a
landscape decline from any state to
Matassa and this is because at least
your bidding we have kind of a crowd
with a large plus size so I visited
those develop models so the feed
statistics reveal that the model which
incorporates additive dominance IP
status seemed to give the best petition
abilities so as you can see here and
this is Instagram showing the
distribution of those prediction
accuracy so this is the I try to
partition the total variance to take the
data Vera's in two different sources as
you can see here the terminus and the
piston system to contribute a very light
effect so so meaning that we cannot
ignore the importance of non-terminals
effect and which means that the model
that has additive a non additive is
likely to give you good producer for
genetic marriage so the lesson learned
from this lesson does the murder that
include additive and not additive effect
the degenerative mary's awkwardly and
the dimness effect is not completely
independent of additive effects so we
need as the overlap and luminance
offends him to play a major role in
inflation fresh sheet so if future work
is to consult with ITIL research team to
assemble the candidate pools from which
you have to from which the authority
Ruby defiles so as they need to explore
what I did the new me traditional method
to compare the result with the assisting
ones so I need to simulate
approachability one their progeny for
each pair of parental combinations so I
give special tasks to my special
committees for your support for the
advice from time to time to all the
member of general group friends for
advice in one way or the other
thanks to Bill Melinda click Bill Gates
UK here for the financial support toward
toward this research work thank you all
for listening
[Applause]
questions have you tried these models so
you do the additive fit and then you add
it on this kernel and then you add an
episodic kernel you actually try to fit
just a dominance or Justin at the static
and compare that to the additive itself
[Music]
so the question is so you have this
thing where you're doing like a nested
right so you start with an additive only
then you have an additive plus dominance
then you have added plus dominance plus
epistasis a question is have you tried
to fit just dominance or just epistasis
it's been my experience that you end up
with really similar prediction at least
in an inbred by modeling only up the
stasis I could end up with really
similar prediction actresses as the only
T I try to do is I did that early this
morning so instead of using the additive
by additive as a epistatic components I
tried to use I did buy dominance to see
what is going to happen but what I
observe is that the the process
heritability is much higher around 0.67
but when I additional policy is almost
the same thing with that of a DT by DT
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu